just before we get into this amazing
video with Luke belmer if you're
interested in leveling up mentally or
financially then you need to join my
free and private telegram group where we
teach you how to make your very first
$10,000 a month online we also talk
about the winning mindset and I even
share with you the different winning
crypto and FX trades that my team and I
are making so I'm going to leave the
link for you in the description below
joining me on the show today we have an
extremely successful entrepreneur who
has actually blown up on the Internet
over the last year and a half he was
born in Argentina and moved to the US at
just 16 years old and worked his way up
all the way from waiting tables
door-to-door sales all the way to being
one of the largest pancake swap holders
and making millions of dollars in
e-commerce it is the co-founder of
Capital Club Luke Balmer Luke welcome to
the show what a wonderful introduction
thank you for having me so good to have
you here I was a little bit stressed
about it cuz you've done so much it's uh
great to be here you've done so much
I've been looking at some of your work
and I think we're going to have a great
conversation because I think we resonate
on a lot of things absolutely and I've
been going through your stuff for the
last year and a half learning a lot from
you but I think what really um struck me
the most was your background you came
from Argentina to the US at 16 years old
which is actually incredibly young so
I'm fascinated how did you make that
move did you come with anyone did you
know where you were going you know how
how do how were you making money you
were waiting tables and then you sort of
put that money into cryp can you explain
that journey of how you got to the US
and built everything up I think the
first thing to understand is that where
there's a will there's a way if you want
to become successful you can be
successful it doesn't matter if you're
16 if you're 14 if you're 22 if you're
30 the moment that you unlock the mental
framework that hey my life can actually
be something more than the village that
I grew up in or the construct that my
parents or the narrative that I've been
uh raised under and thankfully I got
that dat data set unlocked at an early
age at 16 I realized hey my parents were
working regular jobs Argentina had just
defaulted right over the last couple
years with their debt and they were in a
situation whereby the country was pure
socialism I looked at America I'm like I
can literally go and get rich I can go
and build a business I can go and do
things that I want to do now waiting
tables for me was a privilege like I
would go and make $100 in a night I'm
coming from a third world country that
is a lot of money sure I have to pay for
rent and things of this nature but I was
like whoa I'm at the bottom of the
echelon here just getting started and
I'm making a couple hundred dollars a
day what I need to do is get extremely
intelligent so what I started doing is
focusing on unlocking data sets becoming
extremely knowledgeable because I
understood that if I wanted to play the
game of life it couldn't just be
hustling it couldn't just be working
hard I needed a strategy and I need to
learn from people that had strategies
piece those things together find my
winning strategy what it means to be
successful and attack that strategy and
Bitcoin crypto was part of that strategy
why easy multiplier low risk High reward
I was part of the bull run in 2017 I
lost money in the 2017 bull run but I
knew it was going to come back I knew
social media was going to play a massive
part into it because I got into crypto
because of social media so I was like
what I need to do is position myself so
I made a couple
hundred uh well I was about to drop a
big amount of something I was able to
make a good amount of Bitcoin mhm and
when I was when it was a couple hundred
dollars and I had a good stash of
Bitcoin saved up and I realized that all
I needed to do was maintain that money
stashed away because it's hard money and
then just have enough money inside the
system to be able to operate but I'm
starting to move outside of the system
as much as possible because I truly
believe in decentralization and it's not
this decentralization out of the system
it's is understanding that the system is
just one piece of the ingredient and
even though it's kind of a monopoly I
realized early on that I need to make
money in order to be outside of that
system so Bitcoin was one of those
Solutions it worked out well and here we
are today but what confuses me about
this story is I think we're pretty close
in age when I was 16 that's not what I
was thinking so how were you thinking
outside of the system at such a young
age I think you can't
judge how a seed grows in two different
Gardens I think it was just a different
situation for a different individual in
a different time I think it's it's not
so much that I'm a special individual
it's just that I took advantage of the
information and the knowledge that I had
at the time look how many people knew
about Bitcoin before I did look how many
people didn't buy it look how many
people saw that e-commerce and making
money online was going to be a thing and
they didn't capitalize on the
opportunity the difference between me
and somebody else was that I just took
action and I did something with the
information that I had and that's the
difference between a winner and a loser
and the reason I'm a winner is not
because I have a better brain capacity
because my brain processing power is so
much better no I'm actually dedicated to
what to winning and when I realized that
I couldn't make excuses I was fully
reliable for the information that I
absorbed and what I did with that
information I decided to act because
action equals reaction we know this to
be true if there is a cause there's an
effect so if I'm poor something is
causing that poorness I need to be able
to address it I was able to address it
at an early age and that was Financial
illiteracy inadequacy to be in the
market Marketplace and offer value and
that was what I needed to solve become
financially literate and provide value
when you provide value you make money
when you become financially literate you
know how to move your money and keep
your money so many people out here talk
about how to make money bro when you
start playing the game you're going to
understand it's even harder to keep the
money yeah and that's a completely
different game but well that's a
conversation for a different time it is
a conversation for a different time but
it's funny that you that you mention
that because it's such an important
point because we're here in Miami where
everyone's making money but nobody
saving money and you you know you know
things and you hear things about you
know different people and things that
they're doing and nobody's learning how
to save their money everybody gets Rich
really quick but I think it's reverse
narratives I think you need to play
Reverse narratives if people did what
most people don't do they were most
likely going to have different results
AK be successful so if you see that
people are spending money then you need
to ask what are they spending money on
so the problem isn't spending the
problem is what are you spending it on
and does it have a return not just does
it a return does it have a return
towards my predetermined goals you have
to allocate this Fuel and this energy
that all all money is is energy that you
input towards different things that's
why I have no emotional attachment
towards my net worth why because it's
just stored up energy that I'm going to
deploy to empower people to empower
communities to fulfill my dreams to take
care of my family it's Just Energy fuel
it's just a tank you don't look at a a
tank full of gas and somebody has a
little bit of gas and it's like like
you're you're a peasant you're a pie
piece of [__] cuz your Tank's not full
no how can I help you and this way that
you operate in a different Dynamic so
instead of [__] on people hey you
don't have money your reports
understanding hey money doesn't really
mean anything it's just one factor one
spectrum of this entire equation it's a
it's a very interesting conversation I
think the the premise of of our talk
with uh Liberty is also going to be
important the financial independence of
an individual but I genuinely believe it
starts in the brain and it starts in the
mind because you have to become educated
and nobody is going to do it for you and
people that think that they go to the
school system and find true education
you don't you find indoctrination and
people have assumed this idea that the
information they've received is
education and it's truly not so your job
is to go find truth I often talk about
this the scientific method as the
approach to finding truth the scientific
method is tested and proven observation
testing hypothesis and you go through
the entire cycle till you arrive to a
conclusion
in the same way you can have a
scientific method towards your approach
in life you can have a scientific method
Where You observe something and ask
yourself is this true or is it false but
people are like science well what is
science define science what does it what
what is science science if you break it
down to its Most B basic common
denominator basic English 15th century
it basically means to split right to
split and at its Essence it's splitting
what truth from falsehood science
is the process of finding truth so when
you have this hey do you believe in the
science you can't believe science you
know science because science is the
understanding of Truth yeah between
falsehood
and Truth Lardo Da Vinci famously said
study the science of Art and study the
art of science learn how to see realize
that everything connects to everything
else so if everything connects to
everything else how I operate in my
business how I have my mindset how I
move to a different country how I take
risks how I become successful how I lose
money how I go through bad Partnerships
how I do good Partnerships how I treat
my uh my relationships how I interact
with my employees all of that is a
cumulative representation of who I am
the money is just an aspect so when you
peel back the curtains of Luke Belmar
I'm just an individual here trying to
empower others I'm not special I won't
be remembered when it's all said and
done and I'm totally okay with that like
it's not a big deal you might be but if
I'm not it's totally fine and in that
process as long as we can have a great
existence and you leave better today
than you than you were when we first
interacted I think it's uh worthy ideal
to live by so that's kind of a little
bit about me thank you that was a a lot
of information and yeah it was good no I
mean you speak about um it's all about
education and what you do with the
information that you have in front of
you and I mentioned in the introduction
that you are one of the largest pancake
swap holders or one of of the largest
holders of cake so how did you learn
about cake because I know you know you
said you were holding Bitcoin and you
got into Bitcoin really early but how
did you discover cake and how did you
know to buy up so much like talk me
through that just before we hear what
Luke has to say if you love Bitcoin
buying it is not the only way to get
some you can actually earn Bitcoin as
cash back with a Sleek heater purifier
heat bit mini is powered by the same
silicon chips as your iPhones and Macs
it Heats your home by mining Bitcoin at
10 ter has is being as efficient as
industrial mining gear what's more is it
actually accomplishes this while
maintaining energy consumption levels on
par with traditional appliances at just
400 WS not to mention airclean B heper
filters is a lifechanger for anyone who
lives in a big city has pets allergies
or likes cooking mini is quieter than a
fridge it looks great and it's made from
Aviation grade aluminium and I
personally love the black and silver one
and it's the only plug-and playay device
available for people looking to join and
support the Bitcoin network but lack the
technical knowledge or the funds to do
so you're going to heat your house
anyway this winter so why not do it with
heat bit and maybe get one for your
girlfriend or your parents so they can
finally give Bitcoin a try heat bit is
the way Bitcoin mining was supposed to
be from the very start as said by
Satoshi Nakamoto himself in a forum post
back in 2010 if you're interested in
grabbing a heat bit mini I'm leaving all
the relevant links for you in the
description below now let's get back to
Luke yeah so 2015 2016 was when I
started playing with with Bitcoin 2017
took part of the Bull Run 2019 was the
defi Bull Run I was in all of that I was
part of the uni swap air drop I was part
of the entire thing but that was part of
what the echain so as CZ starts creeping
up the ladder in bit in in the Bitcoin
or the crypto ecosystem and he launches
binance I bought I started buying BNB
token at $2 in 2017 so I was I'm a
massive holder of that token because I
was like I can't just bet
on a project I need to bet on people so
I like I'm going to bet on this cat he's
just an absolute Savage on clubhous the
application that's no longer relevant
because they censor everybody
mhm uh he hopped on there and he started
talking about the binance smart chain
and how they was going to grow and
compete with ethereum and it was going
to be a great thing now in order to
compete you need volume you need traffic
he's going to drive that volume going to
drive that traffic you need a competitor
product to what Unis swap what is it
pancake swap it was a direct fork and
who was talking hey uh Hey consider
pancake swap consider the fact that they
have a team overseas I don't know much
about them but here's a little I was
like H those are some data sets that's
some Clues he's probably going to pump
this bag before it was ever listed on uh
binance I was already buying tens of
thousands of units of cake staking them
when I was staking them on pan swap like
the finance website I I think the apy
was like
14,000 that's when it started it was
like ridiculous so I became the top 10
holder of pancake swap in the entire
world and I rode that from like two $25
million market cap to 2.6
billion uh I I like sold on my way up so
I didn't like cash out the top but it
was a good bet so how did you know to
sell on your way up because that's one
of the hardest things in crypto people
just can't hit sell like I can't even
hit sell like there are so many things I
should have sold earlier this year that
I just didn't so how did you know to
sell like how do you how do you get the
the the braak in the courage to sell
it's the plan you I went in with a plan
like I actually executed my Bull Run
plan to the te I did to this bull run
what I wanted to do which was get rich
and get out that was my plan and that's
what I'm telling everybody is like a lot
of you guys saw this bull run next Bull
Run's coming you have the ability to get
rich and get out but you're not doing
what you're supposed to be doing
everything that you said hey I'm going
to do during the bare Market to make
sure I'm ready for the Bull Run you're
not doing it I actually did it and
that's the big difference what did I
spot I spotted the fact that defi was a
trend I spotted the fact that you could
L the icos of 2017 were so difficult to
get involved with because you had to
send money to a metamask that you were
expecting coins in return When smart
contracts rolled out I knew it was going
to prce and I just decided to be part of
the ecosystem you position yourself
early one you understand that the FED
when the FED prints the money has to go
everywhere so it has to allocate itself
in different crevices it's literally
liquidity you throw water into a place
that has rocks the water will fill those
gaps so it filled it in crypto it filled
it in the the ETF markets it filled in
stock markets it filled it in Forex it
filled it in real estate the money went
everywhere you just had to pick whatever
vehicle you wanted to get in and I just
happened to pick one of the vehicles
that had the craziest multiples but
there was plenty of things that went
absolute bananas if somebody pulls up
the chart of tomatoes pull up the chart
of tomatoes they went through the
[__] roof during during but or or
eggs they went through the [__] roof
you could have invested in eggs egg egg
sellers got [__] Rich yeah but you
just had to find your vehicle the people
I got rich were the ones that positioned
themselves and to answer your question
when did I get out when one of the
founders of fazeclan called me and said
hey should I buy safe Moon and I was
like bro this shit's like these guys
don't know anything about crypto like I
know that they don't know anything about
crypto and I know that once they buy
they're going to get excited and push it
to their Community who else is left to
buy after Justin Bieber mhm you know
what I mean when Justin Bieber buys a
million dollar ape what's who's who else
is going to buy it yeah youve reached
the top of the market you've reached the
end of the line so at some point you
just have to say is this enough for me
to live am I good am I willing to leave
the casino oh my God one thing there's
one thing you said um on a podcast I
don't know which podcast but it's
something that me and my brother
actually we were both like that is so
good we need to remember that you said
um small wins that's what you said and
that's something which I really try and
uh digest and incorporate into my
trading you know you don't need to go
for the life-changing money just take as
many wins as you can and then they
accumulate into big wins yes that it's
the compounding principle it's it's the
idea that you understand that the Great
Wall of China not was not built by
deploying the Great Wall of China from
the sky it was built from the ground
Brick by Brick over a long period of
time that when you zoom back you see the
artwork you see the big fund you see the
big amount of money you see the big net
worth but people don't see the fact that
most billionaires have white hair mhm
what does that mean it takes a lifetime
to get rich this idea of getting rich
young it ain't a thing I am an anomaly I
am not the your status normal I
understand that I accept that but I also
understand that there's a process to get
rich and I understand that process and I
can help people through that process now
I'm not the only individual now I don't
have all the answers but I know how to
build an 8 fig portfolio I know how to
build in crypto I know how to build
Ecommerce I know how to scale and build
digital businesses and I think that most
people what they need to focus on right
now isn't oh how do I make a big win
notice how do I keep my habits in check
how do I do what I'm supposed to do
every day people are focused on the
output you truly can't determine whether
the Market's going to go up or down you
can't like you can't make that decision
what you can make is the best financial
decision understanding long-term games
right people are out here oh well I'm
going to make 1% today 3% bro when
you're looking at the charts and you're
FOC all day seeing that ticker go up and
down you could be doing other things you
could be actually making real money
producing cash flow excuse me but the
stock market unless you have some crazy
dividend ecosystem you're not going to
get cash flow the risk reward ratio is
just not there right now so you need to
be able to produce money I think it's
not just about the small wins but it's
about the small wins consistently yes
and most people they have small wins but
then they have a big loss they don't
know when to cut their [__] loss so
all these small wins they're gone
so you need to not only eat and bite
those little small things but you need
to make sure that you don't get eaten up
that really hits home that hits home lot
it happens to all of us it happens to
all of us it's okay it's the process
yeah no it's funny cuz before you came
in actually me and my brother we just
had a a win a medium win it wasn't a
small win it wasn't a a life-changing
win it was a medium win now we got to
decide whether we want to do the win
again or whether we want to leave the
casino you know yeah so that's what
happened literally before you walked in
so that's very relevant that's funny um
may I ask how much did you sell out for
with cake I made a little bit over five
okay yeah it was pretty good but that
was just pancake swap it was pretty good
I want to move on a little bit and
understand Drop Shipping because that
was obviously one of the one of your
most successful businesses you made
millions of dollars in e-commerce so my
first question is how did you know that
drop shipping was going to take off so
Drop Shipping is just a model it's
always existed it's the model of
Arbitrage it existed from the time you
had Marco Polo traveling to China all
the way to you know Europe transacting
with Japan when Japan's borders were
closed you had this concept of Arbitrage
Drop Shipping is just digital Arbitrage
where you're taking a product that you
don't truly own a warehouse a
manufacturer owns it you Market it for a
markup and then you sell it to a
customer that markup is basically what
you get to keep now Drop Shipping the
model of Drop Shipping has existed not
only in selling digital products but it
exists in houses it exists in cars it
exists in basically every sort of asset
or product in the world so understanding
that Drop Shipping is just a model it
it's always existed and it will always
exist it's understanding where the
attention is because where attention
goes money flows so where's the
attention in 2016 2017 2018 on Facebook
100% that's where we all spent our days
we were all here playing [__]
Farmville like let's be real so who's
running your ads
Luke very simple so where the attention
is right now Tik Tok where is Luke on
Tik Tok so where the attention goes
money flows position yourself not only
to be the best in the industry to offer
products of value and service but
understand where the attention where the
audience where the liquidity where the
money is and then you can position
yourself there and I think you can uh
collect some coins a lot of people say
that Drop Shipping is dead but you think
that it's not necessarily dead there's
just a new iteration of it yeah so what
does that look like I mean I just got
back from Hong Kong and I just met with
the top drop shippers in the entire in
all of Hong Kong and they do about $100
million a year in Drop Shipping so when
I have guys that are showing me $100
million worth of annual sales and then I
have a cat here in Miami that's doing
$20,000 a month telling me that Drop
Shipping is dead there's clearly a
discrepancy of knowledge so usually when
I look at the information somebody has a
comment or somebody mentions an idea or
they they burst something out I look at
them and I say what experience does this
person have to and to validate their
claim is this person a good source of
authority to mention is Drop Shipping
alive or dead yeah the answer is most
likely not because if you look at Amazon
if you look at a lot of these companies
a lot of it is based on Drop Shipping
models and it'll continue to exist so
once I realized that drop shipping was
going to exist that there was a big
demand on the internet for products and
that the attention was on social media I
capitalized on it
it's so interesting because it's so new
and um you know we often or I often try
and explain this to um like my parents
or something like that and it's just
something which I think because you know
you talk about who who has the authority
to talk about this and it's just
something that I think only like the
younger generation can really tap into I
don't know perhaps you have a different
opinion break that break that down a
little bit more for me so I I feel like
it's very difficult to explain this to
to the older generation you know you you
although it's just Arbitrage and it's
something which has existed for a very
long time it just seems to be something
which is is a much like a millennial
genz uh skill to have or something to
tap into ABS absolutely I mean it's
definitely a business model that is more
trendy now than it used to be obviously
because arbitraging via QVC in between
ads of your favorite sitcom that was
Drop Shipping that was Drop Shipping
those tele somebody calling selling you
buy one get one free shipping like
that's Drop Shipping except now the
barrier to entry right has been reduced
so people look at Drop Shipping is dead
no Drop Shipping is so alive that
there's so many people trying to compete
for that space so in order for you to
compete instead of being a little [__]
get really good the ones in the market
that win are the best winners win and
losers lose so if you're not making
money and Drop Shipping bro news flash
people are still buying yeah yeah yeah
people whether they're buying or not
yeah is irrelevant I I just got uh back
from a meeting with a mentor it's very
interesting because as you build
relationships with mentors and you
continue to grow you begin to have a
different relationship with your Mentor
it's more kind of like a peer type
relationship so this mentor of mine he's
uh probably done about2 billion in sales
in his lifetime he's an older guy he's
about 70 years old I sat down with him
he's talking about how he's putting
together something for uh you know
Executives and that the executives don't
want to come and and attend his his uh
training that he wants to train CEO
and that you know so many people signed
up but nobody showed up he's like oh
they're all ungrateful and I said no my
friend they're not all ungrateful
they're just somewhere else like their
attention is somewhere else right now
you just you just lost the game of
attention they're most likely scrolling
or doing something they're not not doing
something they're just not doing what
you have them doing because well you
just didn't mark it right so that's my
opinion yeah so of reminds you of when
um people complain online that like the
algorithms change cuz they're not
getting as much engagement it's like no
your content is just it's just no good
anymore and it's the thing is it's not
not about just content one thing is
content other thing is the market yes
just because you have content doesn't
mean you know how to Market in the
entire game of of being online is
there's a factor to it that is
Showmanship what is my Showmanship the
fact that I'm not going to post
constantly the fact that I do whatever
the [__] I want online I have my own
reasons I'm not going to be [__] the
algo I'm not going to on a thumbnail and
do that dumb [__] so that is my strategy
to be successful on social media is
authenticity because now more than ever
people are sick and tired of the
[__] people don't like the I want to
get rich overnight people don't buy that
anymore people want to know how can I
make a consistent living how can I be
good how can I wake up with peace of
mind how can I find a good spouse how
can I have a six-pack and how can I
slowly scale how can I grow I don't want
to hail marry people and I get that you
need to find an ecosystem you need to
find those that information I feel like
the information that's on YouTube it's a
lot of the young cats that don't really
have a lot of life experience uh so I
try to limit the amount of exposure that
I have of myself on there because then
it kind of mixes me up with the rest
that's interesting where would you
rather be if not YouTube in real life
with billionaires on an island fair
enough okay well let's let's get into
that okay so a lot of your content you
know you talk about um Escaping The
Matrix and freeing your mind so I'm
really curious what is the Matrix to you
and how is it that they keep our minds
trapped so today I wrote an email titled
enjoy the weekend but week spelled like
week not week like weekend week like w a
k and it's you will either use this
weekend to get ahead or you will use
this weekend to become weaker and in
that email I wrote something that's
really interesting I said the
Matrix most people observe the Matrix as
an exterior Factor they don't look at
the interior factor of the Matrix which
is the sub programming and the mental
Frameworks and belief systems and the
conditioning that's already been applied
a lot of the losing in life doesn't come
from the exterior system it comes from
the self- sabotage it comes from the
poor decisions that are nurtured from
the time we're born from ages 0 to 7
your brain is in Theta State what is
Theta State Theta state is the time
basically dream state when you go to bed
you're in Theta state that is
reprogramming mode subconscious
reprogramming its deepest form where are
you from 0 to 7
Nickelodeon
Elementary yeah so your entire framework
and your entire mindset of the matrix
it's not just oh here's the the central
bank trying to take my money no no no
this goes back from the moment you're
born eight hours after being born you
get jabbed that's how that's when it
starts so if you want to get into the
matrix it's the fact that your entire
life is been programmed and the moment
you wake up you have X amount of years
retroactively of deprogramming that need
to take place I like mushroom mushrooms
so if you want to do a Heavy D
programming have you ever done mushrooms
no okay you should do mushrooms you
would actually really enjoy them because
mushrooms like shrooms like actual
shrooms psychedelic mushrooms with
psilocybin so I have a thesis for
psilocybin mushrooms and I'm just going
to put this out there because obviously
thesis can't be can they can be tested
but not necessarily uh claimed as a fact
but Japanese scientist um Paul stamet
who's the leading expert on mushrooms uh
observed that there is an experiment
that Japanese scientists did and what
they did is there was a labyrinth that
represented the Japanese the Tokyo
subway system and they planted melium
aka the mushroom and they placed food on
the other side of this virtual toy
version of the subway system and the
mycelium aka the mushroom Through Time
found a more optimized way of finding
the end point AK the food then the
engineers had crafted oh wow the Tokyo
underground Metro System so the entire
Japanese current Metro system is based
on the melium Network's movement wow
because it is intelligent so when you
consume the mushroom you're actually
tapping
into data sets in truth that come from
the earth it's crazy concept but it's
literally just information truth about
yourself cuz it can be very
retrospective it's just information it's
just putting yourself or introspective
it's putting yourself in a state of mind
not in
not in a consistent altering state of
mind but altering your state of mind so
you can perceive reality in a different
way right now you're only perceiving
reality through your eyes but what if
reality isn't just what you
see what if reality is beyond your
senses and what if you have to tap into
it in a different way I hear a lot about
um mushrooms and um like micro doing
mushrooms micro doing hen mushrooms have
only been illegal for 50 years we've
been using mushrooms and getting [__]
up for the last 200,000 years years it's
it's the it's part of spirituality it's
part of human nature it's part of
exploration it's part of getting I'm not
saying go out into crack I'm not saying
that crack isn't like crack is not a
mushroom right it's completely different
thing but I was just mentioning I think
it's a one of the reasons for de
plugging from The Matrix absolutely 100%
it's a half but like how much mushrooms
you know like I is it you mean like
micros sing
it's test test your
journey enjoy life don't take it so
seriously mhm you know maybe smoke a
joint don't tweet about it I'm I don't
like weed smok I don't like don't worry
about it don't I'm just I'm just pulling
your leg do you smoke weed oh and on
occasion very rare I understand the
negative effects of it uh but I I limit
it not a lot yeah yeah fair enough
there's no Nuance a lot for TWI no
Nuance but I will say uh to unplug from
The Matrix to respond to your original
question I think people need to
understand the programming that's tied
into their subconscious mind and they
need to tackle that because every text
whether religious whether it was
Buddhism Islam Christianity it doesn't
matter they all have agreed on one
simple truth as a man thinketh so is he
yeah every text every wise man every
sage has agreed on that fact that how
you perceive reality will dictate your
reality so if you can change the way
that you perceive Reality by
deprogramming the [__] that's been
given to you from the moment you were
born AK that's the Matrix you don't look
at the exterior that which you can't
control that which you can't control
will produce
anxiety state of fear you can't operate
out of a state of fear a lot of these
truth guys out there they're just fear
fear fear fear fear fear fear fear fear
fear you can't that's a low state of
vibration you want to live in a state of
vibration of authenticity and truth and
power and where does that come from
knowledge comes from being certain and
knowing that you can control what you
can control and what you can control the
exterior so be it MH can you define what
data sets are
and um also what are glitches in The
Matrix and can somebody be a glitch in
The Matrix how does that work I know you
talk about that a lot in the movie
Wreck-It Ralph the main character is
this little girl and she's she's a
glitch in the game she's not supposed to
be there she's an anomaly the people in
the game they don't like her but she
understands that if she uses her glitch
she can actually take advantage of the
game this concept of being a glitch in
the system is this idea of
there's a program there's a one two
three 4 of how people should conduct
themselves a glitch operates outside the
Norms of the status quo they Forge their
own path they make their own decisions
and then the programming that they've
been given they glitch out of it and new
programming and that's what's the new
programming the data sets what is the
data set the new software that gets
downloaded from The Ether the mushrooms
or whatever into what the hardware so
it's not just about the software it's
about the hardware and being able to
understand that the software needs to be
compatible with the software Hardware
software compatibility Mind Body every
sage has talked about this Aristotle
talks about this Plato talks about this
mamot Musashi talks about this sunu
talks about this the control of Mind
Body so if you have the data sets of
getting healthy but you don't do
anything with it then did you truly
unlock the data set or were you just
aware of a truth you didn't really
capture the truth so data set is the
download of the software into the
software so that the from the download
of the software into the hardware so
that it changes the hardware to the core
so that the processing system of the
machine is no longer the same but it is
upgraded that is what it means to become
a glitch that is what it means to unlock
data sets and become an anomaly so can
you give me some examples of data sets
like how do people seek out data sets to
help them level up financially or just
in in healthwise in many different ways
when was the the first time you heard
about
Bitcoin um it was in
20 I was 16 okay so 20 I don't know 20
how what year was I in year 13 I don't
ballpark it oh 2013 2013 or or 2014 okay
so let's say 2014 you heard about
Bitcoin you didn't buy it no I didn't
you were given a data set you didn't do
anything with it cuz I didn't trust the
source though I remember because you
didn't trust yourself no I didn't trust
the source you're the
source what do you mean what do you mean
the scientific method you need to put
the data sets through a process to test
whether they're true or not right and I
I didn't test you didn't test it you
didn't test it you just discarded it
yeah I did it was a piece of information
that's just neutral but you had no
mental framework to take it through
therefore you couldn't process that
information because you didn't have the
data set to process because your
Hardware was not compatible yet so you
received the information you just
weren't ready but you can be ready by
upgrading your Hardware which requires
consistent persistent dedicated energy
input so that you can upgrade so that's
kind of like you need to consume books
you need to network you need to get
involved with people you need to develop
hard skills you need to learn how to
sell you need to learn how to interact
with individuals you need to learn how
to balance a checkbook you need to learn
how to manage cash flow you need to
learn all these things so it's a
cumulative of life that allows you to
capitalize on the data sets so it's not
just information it's the fact that you
need to be compatible with that
information in order to capitalize on it
and that is the mindbody connection for
data
sets so if you're not compatible with it
is this a ridiculous question thinking
about it in my head before I say it out
loud but in some ways it's it's almost
like it's like not it's not your fault
if you're not ready to um to take in
that information but then again it is
your fault because you should
continuously try to
there's a duality so The Duality comes
from ignorance is bliss so you don't
know that which you don't know so I
can't expect you to know that which I
you don't know so I'm not going to judge
you like people that don't have money
and don't know about money I can't judge
you like I completely understand brother
I didn't know [__] I'm just getting into
the game myself like I'm I got a couple
million dollars in under my under my
belt there's people that have billions
they know something that I don't so
under this concept that in some way
shape or form it is your fault because
you are responsible for your life even
though I can't blame you simultaneously
I can't blame you but you have to blame
yourself mhm so even though I can't
judge you you have to look at yourself
in the mirror and self judge and be like
why am I in this condition and evaluate
yourself through the scientific method
and look at your action look at cause
and effect effect is I'm broke effect is
I'm fat effect is nobody likes me effect
is I'm not where my life wants to be
what is the what is causing that state
and if you address the cause and it's
usually that's exactly I think I
commented on one of your tweets you said
I I think you mentioned these are the mo
the worst things in life like I think
like sin or something like that right
and you had mentioned like being
transgender
andinis yeah whatever the list is of
what somebody in their personal
worldview considers not compatible to
status quo or what they find to be
normal but is that the cause or is that
the effect of the cause is there a is
there a universal cause that is causing
Humanity to be sick and I believe yes
and it is is a state of what
unenlightenment it's a state of not
being able to separate truth from
falsehood that's all it is the people
that take certain actions in life that
don't seem logical is because they're
not living in truth but I'm not going to
judge them because they're not living in
truth like oh a blind person expecting
them to know where to go I'm going to
lead them with Grace with kindness and
understanding that maybe they don't know
any better yeah and Jesus said it
best when they were about to Stone the
woman who had committed adultery he
wrote In The Sand he said he who is
without sin cast the first
stone and they all walked away because
they were all guilty so when you
understand that you are like everybody
else that you are not above anybody and
that people really just need to be
helped then you understand that the
symptom isn't all the things that are
happening in society
that's just the that's just the effect
what is causing it and that's kind of
what I am focusing on addressing and I
think it comes with resetting the
software resetting the hardware and just
becoming a new person in terms of
resetting software um kind of leads me
on to my my next question which is
something that you said which I thought
was fascinating broism is a condition of
the mind and not the pocket so can you
break this down for me and explain what
can people do to retrain their brain so
that you know they they break out of
that hardware and are able to sort of
you know level up essentially and get
out of that broke mindset the key to
manifestation can be synthesized and
boiled down to potentially one sentence
by who I believe to be probably the
greatest to ever walk the earth which
was Jesus and he
said when you
pray believe that it has been given to
you and it will be given to you not not
pray hope ing that things will happen
and then it'll happen it's believe that
it has already happened and it will
happen what does this mean this means
that how you position yourself how you
have a scarcity mindset about your
future will dictate your future if you
live out of fear you will have a future
that yields that energy input equals
energy output but what if I'm always
thinking I'm a I'm a healthy person I'm
going to become healthy I will it it's
it's impossible not to it is a natural
law cause and effect it's like the law
of gravity if I go up to the top of this
roof and I jump I will not go up I will
go down it's the same with every other
law same as the law of cause and effect
so when you have this kind of idea in
this wrestling and a lot of people have
it and I've had it myself I think people
should understand that there scarcity
mindset or this idea of you know I don't
have opportunity I don't have Network I
don't have money I don't have I don't
have don't have well if you have nothing
you have nothing to lose so you better
go for it and it's that in that mindset
of I have nothing to lose I am wealthy I
have time energy and attention and I
already have that which I want to have I
just have to believe it to be true and
eventually time will catch
up that is how you evolve your mindset
from scarcity to wealth because broke is
not a condition of the pocket it's truly
a condition of the mind because if you
think you're rich and you work towards
that ideal who can stop you do you think
that's true for all aspects of Life yes
because everything is in everything
else everything represents itself in
everything else how you do one thing is
how you do everything how you treat your
brother is how you treat your business
partners how you treat brother is how
you will treat your husband one day it
is just because that's you it's just
it's how it's going to be so the
question is how do you treat those
people because what that is is a
reflection in the mirror of who you are
as a person which is beautiful because
because it can happen to anybody it's
but it's in the self-reflection that
people can kind of improve but it's also
in the self-reflection where people can
get offended truth hurts and many times
I look in the mirror and I don't like
things so I decide to change them and
the difference between the people that
win in life and the ones that lose they
look at the mirror they walk away and
don't change and say everything's
perfect and then the ones that look in
the mirror and they're like there's a
smudge let me clean that and they get
polished
to what extent is doubt detrimental in
manifesting well what is doubt well you
said that what is
doubt doubting that you won't
necessarily what is doubt not believing
that you're going to achieve what you
want to achieve so it's to have this
insecurity yeah of the outcome mhm when
you know something to be true do you
fear whether it's going to happen or not
but how do you know it to be true
because I wield reality hm I control
reality because I control how I perceive
reality and I understand that if I do x
amount of things consistently over x
amount of period of time I can
accomplish anything so Absol you believe
that absolutely everything is in your
control
everything why wouldn't it be because
some things happen which are out of your
control in life yeah because you didn't
level up to the place to put it under
your
control I don't know hopefully I don't
know don't you think don't you think
that like I don't know
let's say give me a scenario okay it's
going to be morbid because we have to
the only way I B deal okay well I don't
know say what a few years from now you
have children something could happen to
your child absolutely and obviously if
if you were fully in control of Life
your child would grow up healthy and
happy but there's a chance that that may
not happen yeah but because and that's
not in your control but that's because
you're looking at the the the life of
the child as the end of the cause and
effect what if it's just a ripple in the
wave of time and you're looking at the
end of the picture and not one of the
ripples so what if what you're looking
at isn't the things that are happening
but at the end of your life when you
evaluate everything you look back and
you said I live the life that I wanted
based on my terms not Everything went
perfect not I controlled everything but
when I'm on my death bed I look back and
I said I beat this game that's it that's
control you can't there's variables to
it yeah you can't control when you're
going to die how long you're going to
live there's variables to that but when
it's all said and done can you control
looking at yourself in the be like I did
what I was supposed to do 100% MH that
makes sense I'm I'm with you I want to
talk about um the ways that the system
Keeps Us enslaved so you know we've
spoken about upgrading our system but
there are obviously ways that we're kept
enslaved and propaganda is one of them
Netflix music social media I think
Netflix is probably one of the worst in
my opinion um and there's the father of
propaganda Edward Benise so can you
explain how he worked with the
government to push out all of this
propaganda and keep us enslaved in the
matrix it's interesting because Edward
beray is actually related to Sigman
Freud and he Sigman Freud is actually
known as the father of psychology so
when you begin to look
at this idea of propaganda well what is
propaganda propaganda is Mass persu
it's persuasion at a mass scale so when
you see narratives being constructed at
a mass scale that is propaganda so
Edward beray is known as the father of
propaganda and he's actually related to
Sigman Freud who is the Godfather of
modern day psychology and this idea of
like atheistic psychology which kind of
makes sense as to what worldviews are
being pushed currently they're also
related to uh the owner of Netflix so
all this kind of connection is really
interesting but what is propaganda
propaganda is just messaging it's just
narratives when you see a narrative play
over a big group of people there is a
controlling factor to that so when
there's a narrative that is propagated
prop propagated prop to elevate
something above everything else when you
prop a narrative now everybody can see
it and you Limelight and focus on it
where attention goes money fls where was
the attention the last couple couple
years social media Tik Tok oh yeah yeah
oh the magic stuff yeah yeah trillions
the magic medicine trillions so where
attention goes energy flows and if you
can prop up your propaganda your message
then you can direct attention it's all
about money then you can monetize it
it's all about money explain the Netflix
connection because that's really
interesting because I personally find
Netflix really difficult to watch these
days cuz it's so woke um and anything
which is like slightly good there's a
little bit of woke sprinkled in there
and you just have to sort of you know
move past it everything is so woke I
find Netflix to be one of the biggest
propaganda machines out there so can you
explain that connection between Edward
and yeah so so one of the co-founders of
uh of Netflix is is related to Edward
Bay and it's just interesting that your
modern-day entertainment is basically
your relationship with former day
propaganda it's just interesting but I
agree with you I think I don't like
consuming anything unless I know the
source of the intent the source of the
intent needs to be the desirability of
the information why you consume
something needs to be scrutinized so why
do I read aristotles why do I dive into
the work of leardo Da Vinci why do I
stay away from Travis Scott music and
and garbage why no offense no offense to
any artist they can do whatever they
want but what they're feeding isn't
filling me
so I need to find what fills me and
somebody that's in a low vibrational
frequency those low vibrational
frequency things they fill them up but
it's just no longer what feeds me and
you have to go from nurturing yourself
with garbage and processed [__] of
the system to finding hey like why am I
listening to this music what is this
causing in me yeah I'm watching these
these shows okay it's making me perceive
women in a different way it is this what
I want and you need to be able to have
what
intentionality towards who possesses
your mind because if you're not in
control of your mind somebody will
control your mind for you and social
media companies video game companies
movie companies music companies they
hire psychologists just like Edward
beray even better than Edward Bernay to
[__] with your head to keep you
controlled why do you think it's just
normal that at 11:15 in the afternoon
you always check your phone and it
buzzes and you feel angst inside that
hey like what's going on and you like
you know refreshing your phone like a
lottery slot that's that's all that's
all programming that is all intentional
dopamine hit dopamine hit disg oh
refresh what's new on the feed what's
new on the feed hooked Psychology 101 if
you do not control your mind somebody
else will control it for you yeah it's
really interesting um when I was uh
about 10 years ago worked on a summer
camp in America and um I was hosting
like this little radio class for some
young kids um and it was I've always
kind of been aware of these things but
it was actually at that moment that I
realized how dirty the music is because
you had these like really young girls
doing karaoke to like a mega trainer
song which is something like I don't
know can't remember the line but it was
if you treat me right maybe you can get
head and I'm like a little child just
said that you know and it was at that
moment that I realized yeah like the the
music is terrible I mean Sam Smith is
just promoting the devil which to me is
fascinating I mean it it's you you
promote that which you love and at the
end of the day people just push what
they love and what you're seeing is just
louder voices and your attention is if
nobody gave attention to the fat [__]
wearing a tight Pink Suit wearing devil
horns if nobody gave a flying [__] about
him nobody would talk about him but
everybody's focused on somebody else's
[__] and watching some dude perform with
a yellow or red cane looking like the
devil instead of focusing on their own
bag how to level themselves up how to
get their parents out of poverty dude if
you're focused on your own [__] like
when people start talking about these I
don't give a [__] dude like I have to
take care of my parents I have to make
sure my community is good I have to I
have to I have to make sure I have safe
havens all around the world after that
that's all done then we can talk about
what's happening in culture right no and
it's and it's a great point it's a great
point it's it's even down to like taking
hate online like my my brother will say
to me he'll be like we don't have time
to worry about what people say about you
we've got to do this we've got to do
that we've got to save Mom and Dad we've
got to you know we don't have time to
worry about all of that um but you
mentioned you know where the attention
flows the money goes and one of the
places um was you know the magic
medicine um so that kind of leads me on
to the next thing that I wanted to speak
with you about I want to understand how
and where the pharmaceutical industry
come into this um particularly in
America and I guess if you feel that
that's true throughout the rest of the
world a synonym for patient is client a
synonym for patient is
client in order for you to have clients
your clients need to come in in order
for a business to operate you need
customers in order for a hospital to be
full you need sick people so Pharma gets
in bed with food gets in bed with every
other industry at the highest level just
look at the shareholders go to yahoo.
finance and you'll be able to see who
shareholds and owns the companies to
prop a message right to then make money
in this case what's the message that you
prop seed oils are good processed food
is good porn's good terrible music is
good not exercising is good taking all
these experimental uh
medications this is good why because
there's a back door to it there's back
deals happening to it that's all money
every single last bit of it so it's
beyond just a jab it's beyond just one
individual thing it's every [__]
aspect of all of existence even outside
of people you can look at the veterinary
industry if you think they vaccinate
people just look at how much they
vaccinate the animals that you eat yeah
you're eating Jabs on Jabs on Jabs on
antibiotics on anabolic steroid oids on
all this garbage on hormones and people
think that they're healthy that they're
developing all these things so the
system is kind of [__] up all around
you really have to just unplug from the
entire thing all of it and evaluate
every aspect of your life the whole
thing's rotten but it's so difficult so
I wasn't going to get to this yet but
since we're here I'll just get because
it's not even Pharma that's why I'm
saying it's it's not even one thing it's
the entire thing is just [__] the
entire thing you have to be outside of
it and understand how everything's
working so that you're not susceptible
to the garbage
to what extent do you think you're out
outside of
it it's a great
question I'll let you know when I when I
find out the reason I ask is because
it's very difficult um especially in
America because the food here is worse
and I hands down say that cuz the minute
I got here every time I go out for
dinner I put on weight every time I go
out for dinner then don't go out to
dinner I know it's okay I deal with it
but I'm just saying but you can go out
for dinner in England and you don't blow
up as much just because of how the food
is processed different different
different matrixes right different
Matrix have different games
no damn that's very true so you have to
operate differently in different places
wow that's very powerful L let me give
you an example when I go to when I go to
Hong Kong they love pork they love seed
oils so most places I can't eat so guess
what I'll just fast so I have to adapt
my Hardware to the
environment does a computer operate well
underwater or in Rain no it's most
likely going to Short Circuit so I need
to make sure that I'm playing in every
Matrix different jurisdictions different
places by the rules of that thing to
make sure I'm
intact so how do you so my question is
how do you deal with it in America
because my brother and I were really
trying to eat healthy right um so we
went on this crazy diet to try and
Source the best meat that isn't
vaccinated and you know we went to like
the farmers market we tried to buy from
Amish farms and it's just very difficult
when you're like building a business and
you know you're trying to work you're
trying to do a million things and then
you've got to stop your day cuz you're
starving and go an hour to a farmer's
market get raw milk there you it's very
impractical it looks like you don't have
a good team yeah I mean may maybe yeah
no yes it does because your job there's
income making skills and then there's
like living things that need to be
handled like I need to fix a tire but
the amount of time and energy that you
expend cooking going to the farm
farmer's market getting in your car gas
in your car that's all peasant tasks
that's just the truth yeah yeah your
goal is to be beyond that so that you
have somebody sourcing your quality food
do you think I read my agreements yeah
after my entire legal team goes through
it do you think I Source my food yeah
I'll go Source my food and then I'll
have somebody go and pick it on a
consistent basis and go and buy things
I'm not going to fix my car I'm not
going to go and re-register my license
place I'll have people do all those
things for me so yes it's an
inconvenience how are you going to solve
it mhm make more money there you go
and how so what does your diet look like
and how much do you exercise minced meat
every single day minced meat uh either
elk or deer or uh
bison Japanese rice quino that's it
vegetables maybe some eggs you have
vegetables yeah you have eggs a little
bit I'm pretty chill on my diet M yeah
I'm pretty basic you said something
earlier you said different matrixes in
different places implying that different
jurisdictions play different games I
know you're extremely well traveled I've
follow you obviously a lot on social
media tell me what do different
countries play like England Japan tell
me so you have different rules in
different places there's different
Monopoly boards there's macr Monopoly
boards and then there micr Monopoly
boards where you need to what you need
to understand is the game that you're
currently in what are the rules and then
understand that outside that game in
other places there's different rules so
your goal is to understand how the game
is played and this specific area so what
is the food in Europe what is the
taxation in Europe what is the culture
in Europe culture you say Luke cult cult
what is a cult so we have culture and
then we have Matrix what is a Matrix
Matrix comes from the word matce matrice
from the Latin comes birth right so the
Matrix is a birth system something
that's created right so you have a
pre-created system and then you have
something that's that's propped up right
so you have a propped up narrative you
have a artificially created ecosystem
and between a narrative and between an
ecosystem you have people so what you
need to understand is that you are bound
to both of those things because you are
a person you have a tax identification
number a social security number you are
part of the system so in anytime you
enter that jurisdiction you have to play
by those rules and people they think
that they can just hop around that
things are just willy-nilly that they
can just go open up Bank accounts that
they can just go and [__] around with
their credit score and their credit
cards and they just buy Bitcoin and they
just [__] around online and say whatever
they want they don't understand how the
game is played sometimes it's important
to understand the game is played because
the biggest [__] you that you can say to
the system is I've crossed all my tees
and dotted all my eyes I am untouchable
everything that I've done is perfect
when they look at your books they can't
[__] with you when they look at
everything you've done they they can't
touch you the ultimate [__] you to the
system is being so clean that they can't
touch you you're down in Puerto Rico yes
you don't have to
answer what's the Matrix there like what
do you have to that's yeah so what do
you have to yeah so the The Matrix in in
Puerto Rico is like an interesting one
right you have a lot of extremely
successful people but then you're also
in in an area that doesn't Tech
technically belong to you right so the
US came they just took over Puerto Rico
they kind of colonized it now have a ton
of Rich guys that are going in there and
basically paying no tax so the people
there are kind of like pissed but the
locals are nice and the weather's really
nice so maybe we run up a part two in
Puerto Rico you can come check out the
The Matrix out there okay for sure all
right done we'll leave it that okay
let's let's move on to talk about crypto
speaking of crypto I know there's a lot
of uh successful crypto people down in
Puerto Rico um but you know you made a
lot of money obviously from Cake um I
think you made some money on lunar or
you shorted lunar or something like that
um I was on your website and I saw that
you actually had uh Satoshi nakamoto's
white paper as the 11th recommended uh
read on your on your website which I
thought was fascinating so you're
clearly extremely Pro crypto Pro Bitcoin
um do you see a difference between
Bitcoin and crypto do you see Bitcoin
being um better in any way so I'm not
passionate about Bitcoin because passion
entails emotion okay I'm not emotional
about Bitcoin Bitcoin is the best
vehicle for money period that's a that's
a fact anybody that transacts and moves
a lot of money besides the discrepancy
of price AK price being correlated to
USD because we happen to live in a USD
World we're bound to it if you think
Bitcoin is going to disrupt US dollar in
the next 30 40 50 like you're just wrong
it's not going to be a thing they could
literally destroy Bitcoin if they truly
wanted to overnight but I think that
it's a vehicle that is going to exist
long term why because you can actually
hold it and that is the most valuable
thing that Bitcoin has it's not
transparent bitcoin's Ledger is not
transparent you can trace everything on
bitcoin but you can hold your Bitcoin
and you can have your Bitcoin and you
can transact your own Bitcoin and you
can do things with Bitcoin that you
can't do with other tokens because one
they don't hold the same value two
they're redeemed Securities they're not
real really money Bitcoin is money
anytime money is considered money in any
jurisdiction the IMF considers that
legal tender where is Bitcoin considered
Money El savador exactly so Bitcoin by
law internationally is legal tender so
Bitcoin by law is the best money that we
have in society now this idea of central
why do I like it yeah I like it because
I have the ability to do whatever I want
wherever I want however I want yeah the
purchasing power May differ but that's
simply because we're quantifying it in
dollars but this concept of
centralization this centralized economy
is a New Concept JP Morgan introduced
this
concept when Banks were Regional so
Banks would operate at a state level
right they would operate if you would
you [__] up your banking relationships
in New Hampshire you could go down to
Florida in Bank in Florida it wouldn't
be a big deal but he introduced this
concept of centralization which is what
conglomerating all the individual nodes
so you can manage them Bitcoin is
powerful because you can operate and
transact with every node every
individual on the system you can
interact with them you can transact with
them it's not just the fact that you can
transact it's the fact that you can
transact with anyone that's what makes
Bitcoin [__] unbelievable one two the
fact that you can physically move any
amounts of
Bitcoin instantly physically one flight
I can take $100 million worth of bitcoin
anywhere in the world that's absolutely
insane so Bitcoin to me is the hardest
money because it is programmed to be
successful whether it becomes successful
or not it's determined to be tested
because once again it's just a financial
instrument so financial instruments need
adoption financial instruments need
faith and financial Al instruments need
trust so if you look at what money needs
in order for it to be money trust a
means of Exchange in a store of value
Bitcoin meets the definition of money so
Bitcoin is money but I don't see it as a
passion like Oh I'm a Bitcoin no no no I
am passionate about my survival and if
that means that Bitcoin is what I need
to hold which is what it looks like it's
going to be or something along this line
of being outside of the system at least
part of
me then that's what I'm going to do
strategy MH I understand Bitcoin is a
good part of the strategy but what's
interesting is there's a lot of people
that think Bitcoin is uh was created by
the CIA a lot of people say that because
Michael sailor is actually so passionate
about it and has I think over 150,000
coins or micro strategy has that you
know he CIA um I think it was Dan Penner
who said that he believes that satosh
Nakamoto is Vladimir Putin and if that
was ever revealed it would be to all of
our detriment do you have a take on the
founder of Bitcoin do you think there's
some kind of sinister founder behind it
or do you think it's genuinely
programmed to be successful to be for
the People by the people and and so on I
mean no no offense to Dan Pena but if
you ask the man to turn on the computer
you can't do it there you go yeah so you
it's not just just because you're an
expert in one thing doesn't mean you're
an expert in everything and at the end
of the day it's like usdt right usdt
right now is super safe why because
there's plenty of liquidity so from a
risk reward ratio you don't think usdt
is not going to go to zero overnight
there's literally there's literally tens
of billions of dollars of cash same
thing with usdc you never thought usdc
was going to be dep pegged but you
didn't know that they were at at the svb
bank and they got dep pegged but then it
reped when they rebalanced their books
but the whole point is you need to be
operating cross cross Dimensions cross
currencies we're going back to if you
want to be decentralized you got to be
moving all over the board all over the
board you can't just be stuck with USD
in One bank account you're you're you're
asking to get [__] yeah you have to
diversify and you have to literally
decentralize yourself you have to
decentralize yourself why because when
you decentralize yourself you
decentralize your risk it's like very
simple concept of wealth preservation
which nobody talks about because
everybody's trying to make money but
once you make the money then you realize
keeping it is even harder so it's best
to at least get some sort of preparation
ahead of time but who do you think
creates a Bitcoin no idea I don't really
care actually who created the US
I actually don't know the answer to that
oh yeah the FED I mean I mean wait wait
wait to the US dollar it was just an
evolution of time right I mean the
current US dollar that we have was is a
result of 1971 when we came off the gold
standard so that's the exactly the point
right it's just iterations of iterations
of iterations of iterations my goal is
just to find the best vehicle of money
if I find a better vehicle of money than
Bitcoin in the future I'll take it yeah
like that's it there is no hotal
[__] you know why because everybody
that's telling you to hodal they're
going to sell on your ass yes that is so
true you know I find that such an
interesting point I've been in the space
a while so I've seen a lot basically so
it's very true yeah and and it's funny
because um there's a lot of false
narratives that they feed you to keep
you holding um so yeah that's why it's
the same narratives the the banks feed
you to keep your balance in the in their
in their bank accounts that's the only
way the system continues running the
only system runs is because you complain
about the The Matrix but you have a bank
account mhm so you're part of the Matrix
and that's the that's you have to play
the game as you say but that's the thing
that's the hypocrisy that's where it
comes in is you want to beat the game
but you only beat the game by playing
the game and you have to become a player
of the game and that's where you have to
play the game without losing yourself MH
and that is where you win is making sure
that your morals your uh values your
principles your ethics your reason for
existence is not jeopardized when you
play the game and then want to get out
yeah that's very true I think that
became um really apparent during uh
during the flu time for when travel
became restricted you know and you you
had you had to ask yourself like what
are my options what do I do um and you
know some people sold their soul so that
they could travel other people found
more Creative Solutions um and it was
interesting seeing because you know I
have very similar opinions to a lot of
different people and it was interesting
seeing how different people navigated
certain things um and I I I wouldn't do
certain things that other people did
sold cuz they had they needed the to pay
to pay the price exactly so your goal is
to have the so you can pay any price
that was done so well that was said very
well speaking of crypto and you know how
the future is going to look AI is
something which is uh blowing up right
now firstly I want to get your take on
AI in general do you like it do you
think that it's going to be Mass adopted
do you think it's really you know the
next big thing and then also what does
it mean for young entrepreneurs how do
how do they make how do we make sure
that 9 9% of all these jobs aren't going
to become people aren't going to become
basically obsolete because it's looking
like that's the way it's going people
will become obsolete but that's not
necessarily a bad thing people only
become Obsolete and it becomes a bad
situation if people stay how people
currently are if you want to capitalize
on AI in a way that is benevolent you
have to allow AI to take on the
industrial work of society and focus
Humanity on the sciences and the Arts in
the Renaissance we are in an age of
Darkness we are in an age where people
hate knowledge people hate the
truth right the Bible says at the end of
times people will call good bad and bad
good so the question is what is the end
of is it the end of times of existence
or is it the end of this time and is
there a great reset coming apparently
there's a thinker by the name of Jordan
Greenhall he probably has like 11 11,000
followers you'll probably have a ton
more after I say this and he talks about
this concept known as uh digital tribal
formations and this concept of this
macro social media economy coming down
into micro communities AI can't replace
a couple things AI can't replace
Community AI can't replace personal
development and AI can't replace your
emotional state like you still have to
regulate your emotional state those
three things are really human and they
can only be satisfied through human
interaction so this concept of digital
tribal formations is that people are
yearning for relationships people people
are yearning for connections so build AI
proof companies by understanding what AI
can't and will not be able to satisfy in
the future now ai being able to replace
humanity is in certain tasks Is Not a
Bad
Thing throughout history we've always
had this double-edged sword of
everything right the gun can be a great
invention the cannon can be a great
invention but it can also be used for
Destruction an airplane can be used for
good but it can also be used to drop a
nuclear bomb so we don't look at
Innovation under the premise of
potentially somebody will use it to
cause a lot of harm but how can we use
this and equip ourselves understanding
that through Mor's law which is the fact
that techn technology is advancing
rapidly and becoming super powerful and
extremely cheap at an esur exponential
curve that we can't even manage the
moment you buy an iPhone it becomes
obsolete like the tech is already
obsolete like that shit's probably a
couple years old it's like not even a
thing anymore so things are moving
extremely quick AI is moving quick so
your goals how can I use AI not
integrate with it please God don't
integrate with AI like you're just
asking to get controlled like a like a
superbot I don't want to go into the
details of the people that are pretty
involved in this this this ecosystem but
just be super careful however there is
also this idea of a new digital
Renaissance and a Renaissance where
people focus on the sciences and the
Arts because we're truly in a dark age
of knowledge people have convoluted
truth and falsehood and there is no
absolute truth and truth must be there
must be an absolute truth because there
must be a way in a philosophy of life so
if there's a way in a philosophy of life
and there's this idea of good and bad
and there's this concept of you know
this digital tribal formation and you
want to find your little group of people
first you need to find those people that
resonate with you which is why you're a
Creator you're finding those people
resonate with your message building this
kind of AI proof ecosystem but also
using AI so to to do what Empower your
organization Empower you to do what not
the task that you want to do would you
if you were living in 200 years would
you send your robot to pick up the
groceries for you 100% right so it's
just using technology to your advantage
as opposed to being scared from it
capitalize on it period if AI is going
to get powerful you better have some
strong AI to compete against it that's
it you're not what are you going to do
complain yeah nobody cares well speaking
of AI Elon mus is one of those people
who sort of leading the way you know
with uh with the with the chips that he
wants to put in people's brain and even
you know free speech and and all this
I'm just curious what what do you think
about Twitter nowadays um people say you
know there's free speech on there but
today I saw I think Jake Shields got
banned or he had something taken down
for saying something rude how how are
you enjoying Twitter what do you think
about the the state of Free Speech right
now so first of all freedom of speech
doesn't exist period across the board
right because if you're operating within
the terms and conditions that you
haven't even read yeah like you're
already saying what you agree to and
most people that are getting terminated
well they're just breaking the terms and
conditions so when you're in the
centralized system they don't owe you
anything so you just have to play the
game and what I came to realize was when
uh Alexander the Great took the throne
arist botles came back from E from exile
for one simple reason which was what
which was he came back from
Exile because he had been ostracized and
removed for talking politics so he got
involved where he shouldn't have gotten
involved and it caus him his livelihood
and when he came back to deal with
Alexander the Great as his mentor guess
what topic he didn't Converse about in
the public
Arena politics at that time why because
it just it didn't make sense strategic
so sometimes not talking is the best
strategy sometimes changing through
action anybody can
tweet few people are actually out here
doing stuff anybody can comment on
somebody's social media platform that
you have no right to even own or use it
doesn't [__] matter if you have a
million followers like nobody gives a
[__] this guy just literally took that
handle at X right that probably somebody
had for like years it's not crazy he
owns it he paid 50 [__] billion
dollar for the code he can do whatever
he wants it's not crazy if you were in
the situation you'd take all the
usernames you'd take your first name and
that and you'd verify that [__] three
times take L at Lea G out Gideon so I I
don't blame him but under this premise
Elon Musk is developing what is called
the super app so he's coming to compete
with your WeChat he's coming to compete
with your Ali pay because you need a
super app in North America and it's not
going to be a super app controlled by
China but it's still they want control
Elon was a tempting to do this in the
x.com days with PayPal but when he went
on vacation you know you had Peter teal
you had the YouTube guys the PayPal
Mafia right they came together and they
B built PayPal they kicked them out but
his premise at the time was to create X
and it just didn't work so he just went
on to shoot rockets and do some crazy
stuff came around back around and now
he's trying to build the super app so if
you look at X it already has the ability
to remit payments in all 50 states so
it's already a financial institution uh
the owner owners you have crazy owners
in there it's a privately held company
so you have no idea what's going on
behind the scenes you have no idea
what's going on behind the scenes and
now you have Elon that owns the
satellites of the internet he owns the
chip that con connects to your brain he
owns the AI and he owns a social media
platform that is powering the knowledge
base of the AI no wonder you want
freedom of speech because you want
people to say everything of everything
of everything so that the AI learns
everything of everything of everything
of everything so that you feed it to
your neural link that is connected to
your
satellites I don't know I mean if you if
you put all these scenarios in a comic
book it's a it's a scenario and a recipe
for disaster who knows we either have a
we either have a savior or we have Lex
Luthor but when somebody wears a new
world order uh jacket I'm not too uh did
he is that did he wear one cue the photo
oh cue the photo I need to take a look
have you seen that good you seen I
haven't seen it I need to take a look
people are going to trip on that one
yeah wow so your so are you a fan you're
not a fan are you just neutral and
observing I am a admirer of the conquest
for sure I respect that he's conquering
at the end of the day individuals
realize
that you have to kill or be killed and
when you're playing at the game that
these guys are playing the world stage
it's pretty ruthless so I I understand
but there's also other narratives
attached to it that kind of freaked me
out a little bit the like controlling
people through AI I don't see how it's
going to be relevant in the near future
but uh 40 50 years from now imagine
people just get activated to the
internet and now they're being told what
to do and how to feel and how to think
and if people think that that's
farfetched yeah it's pretty close yeah
they're pretty naive no I agree with you
yeah all right so we're coming towards
the end of the podcast um and I want to
give everybody that's watching a lot of
value so for those who are you know
building their businesses right now I
think what is it like like 80 to 90% of
all new businesses fail something like
that yes within their first two years
right so how can somebody increase the
chances of having a more successful
business I think that there's a few key
ingredients to every organization
succeeding and I think that first of all
you need to go into business knowing
that it's going to be hard and knowing
that it's going to be most
likely a bust I've done so many
companies that just don't work and you
see Capital Club now doing millions of
dollars thriving that wasn't my first
Rodeo shows just part of the game so
first understanding that when you begin
your entrepreneurship Journey you're
going to take a lot of L's and that
that's totally okay you can't treat
yourself as somebody that's supposed to
be winning all the time when you are in
learning stage so what I see a lot of
entrepreneurs do is they go into the
game thinking that they're going to make
millions of dollars right off the bat
become the hottest guy in the game they
don't really want to earn their stripes
they don't want to really work for it
they don't want to season themselves and
when you become inex experience and you
go into the marketplace that's when you
get punched it's like playing at a level
that you're not allowed to play and in
in the marketplace and in business you
will only be able to be at the level
that you deserve to be at if not you
will be smoked out the con artists
always get caught out they always get
caught so you need to be authentic where
you're currently at and then focus on
leveling up your skills now what are the
skills that if you're getting started
with your business or if you want to run
a successful business you need to take
in mind there are three types of skills
first is income producing skills you
need to focus on how to make money it's
fine if you have a vision it's fine if
you have goals but if you can't feed
these goals then nothing's going to
happen so you need to focus on income
producing skills learn how to sell learn
how to persuade and learn how to talk to
people if you can learn these three
things most of your coverage when it
comes to selling producing income is
going to take place period two is your
income two is your income management
skills you need to be able to manage the
money that actually comes in you need to
learn basic accounting you need to learn
basic law like how do I file an EIN
correctly how do I actually open up a
bank account the right way what are the
banking rules and policies that I need
to follow in order to be in good
standing how do I make sure the IRS
understands what my business is doing
and that it's completely transparent so
you need to have your cash management
skills in check you need to have your
income producing skills and you need to
have your estate SL wealth preservation
skills which is learning how to invest
learning how to buy real estate these
are the three Pockets create multiply
preserve so you need to learn how to
create money which is very simple
sweat time energy and attention you
can't cut it like you have to put in the
hours but then you have to go into
multiplication stage it's a completely
different set of skills some people are
here and they never get out of the
hustle they're always hustling
but at some point you have to transition
which means you need a different
framework of mind you need different
skill sets what are those skill sets you
need to be more aware of Finance you
need to be more aware of your bankroll
you need to be more aware of your
expenditure when you have a lot of money
bro you're not managing your cash flow
and your expenses assuming that money is
always going to come in so if you're
making money but not multiplying it
you're always giving up your Ty now
you're multiplying your money if you
don't know how to keep it you're wasting
your time when you were creating it M so
mindset needs to be completely different
you need to evaluate where you currently
are in your life and ask yourself how do
I get to the next stage and evaluate the
people that are the next stage and ask
them simple ask people I ask people so
many questions I have my Bankers that
manage my money my wealth management
Bankers I ask them questions like hey do
you have like any advice on how I should
invest my money do you have any advice
on like how I should wire money do you
have any advice on I how I should talk
to other bankers and I ask these guys
for advice on how to get to the next
level so what do you need to do find
those people put yourself in the right
rooms what did we talk about selling
persuading networking that is the basis
what are you selling people on sell sell
people on the ability to help you sell
people on the ability to give you the
right information to get to the next
level right it's all relationships so
learn how to create money build a
sustainable business there's three ways
to build businesses digital businesses
physical businesses or you can have uh
services that's it pick one Services
tends to be low risk High reward because
it's just a lot of hustle like you can
go render a service but you have to
expend time on the multiplic
multiplication stage learn how to invest
learn about dividends learn how to buy
real estate and on the multiplication
stage is learn how to build you know uh
CDs or cash deposits learn how to uh buy
t- bills and learn how to buy a little
bit more solid less kind of insanity
some gold some Bitcoin buy some other
currencies but these require all
different Frameworks and I think that
people what they want to do is all these
things at once MH so they're like I want
to make money but then I also want to
invest the money I want to get super
rich it's like no no there's a reason
why the billionaires have white hair and
that I think is the big premise of this
entire podcast and we can kind of wrap
it with that which is the Journey of a
glitch the Journey of becoming somebody
it's lifelong yeah becoming wealthy like
our objective here shouldn't be we do
one podcast and it's over it's we bu
build a relationship right this is the
beginning of a of a relationship of a
friendship of hopefully 40 50 60 years
down the road I can see you succeeding
right so my hope is that you don't just
succeed today with this podcast but that
this podcast is a stepping stone towards
whatever is the future goal and that
your goal is to do long-term business
with long-term people and you want to do
long-term business not this side hustle
[__] so long-term perspective be calm
with yourself understand that it's your
journey look at all the rich people
realize that they have white hair and
the only guy that doesn't have white
hair they're like the super Geniuses and
that you most likely are not going to
fit that category so with enough time
enough dedication laying These Bricks
consistently focusing on income
producing skills multiplication skills
preservation skills and just taking it a
day at a time being authentic
understanding that the system is the
system but most times the system that we
cause and the self damage that we cause
is worse than what comes from the
outside and if we can regulate these
things
regulate ourselves then we can actually
be in control of Our Lives we can't
control a ton of the variables but at
the end of the day when it's all said
and done if you look at yourself in the
mirror and you said well done what else
matters yeah know it's an amazing way to
put it um and that's that's really
interesting a lot of it's very
interesting in the fact you know you
can't do everything and you have to
start somewhere and you have to pick
what you want to do it's it's
opportunity cost like you just have to
pick what you're going to do you can't
take every train so your goal goal is to
do what apply the scientific method to
evaluate what's the best train to take
what is my what is the best vehicle for
me to get to my goal maybe your goal
isn't to get rich that's okay like maybe
your goal is to become healthy you can
have a different goal at a different
time wow yeah you can change your goal
tomorrow you're not bound to your goal
you're not bound to your identity so
maybe today you just have to get fit
maybe tomorrow your goal is to have a
good attitude maybe the next day you you
know what I mean today I was I was in
the Uber coming here and I literally did
20 minutes of breath work in because I
just wasn't feeling good it's like I had
a lot of [__] going on but that was my
task for the moment I wasn't about
making money I had known when you walked
in so well then we're good goal achiev
then we're good then everything has
achieved right so the per the thing is
there's a Harmony of life and there's so
many things to balance in life and to
treat yourself with compassion to treat
yourself as a student of life to treat
yourself as somebody that's on the
journey and we can band together be
humble be honest be [__] human and
understand that we're all trying to
figure this out on this [__] whether
it's a ball of mud or a plate of mud
running through space who [__] knows
or a shape of a durito doesn't really
make a difference the point is we're all
in this [__] together so we might as
well have a good time work collectively
Build Together be authentic be good
people and hopefully we don't nuke each
other in the process yeah well said just
finally what are you currently working
on now that you can share with us and
how can people um follow you get in
touch with you um if maybe if they want
to work with you or anything like that
Luke Belmar everywhere uh and Capital
Club I've been building Capital Club
since
2019 my premise was very simple I wanted
to build an AI proof company with
entrepreneurs that really wanted to
level up break free from the status quo
of their culture of their programming
and right now the cumulative revenue of
all club members is over $5 billion a
year wow so we are a billion dollar club
and we're only growing and my goal is
just to be able to unite as many people
and hopefully they can leave better than
when they first met me and if that can
happen then Capital club's done its job
well I feel like I'm going to leave
better I leave better too I had a good
time yeah so no I feel like I learned a
lot I really did um there's one thing I
oh the one thing that I will really take
away that I really liked which was just
personal for me uh was the the whole
manifesting thing and just like really
just believing that was that's L
powerful
it's so powerful because once you
understand that you can control the
future of your life it gives you the
single most
powerful emotion that you can feel hope
and most people live in a state of quiet
desperation they can't pay their bills
they don't feel healthy they wake up and
they're anxious so why are these things
taking place and if you can address that
and understand that if you want to feel
different you must believe that that
what you want is already yours and that
time space continuum just has to catch
up yeah I thought that was really
powerful you can live a great life well
Luke thank you so much for coming on the
show um thank you so much for going into
so much detail and so many different
topics thought it was really valuable so
thank you so much thanks for having me
guys thank you so much for watching if
you enjoyed this show then don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe and
of course follow Luke on social media
there's just so much Val that we'll see
you next week